مستوضح من اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي الوقفايز انت متابع
لهذه الهجمات المكثفه طوال الايام الماضيه
الاوكرانيه بعضها يعلن عنه ويعني بعضها لا
يتم تبنيه هذا الحادث المستمر لان حاكم
يتحدث عن
احتماليه وقوع هجوم اخر ويطلب من الناس
عدم مغادره المنازل كيف تقرا هذا الهجوم
الحالي في في سياقه كما قل كما قلنا
المكثف في الاسابيع الماضيه
يعني منذ
قصف جسر كيرش بالمره الاولى ولم تعلن
اوكرانيا مسؤوليه
تتالت الاحداث وتنوعت الاحداث بين هجمات
على جسر كرش سواء كانت ناجحه او فاشله
تفضي الى ايقاف وتعليق الحركه لفتره مؤقته
تحولت الهجومات باتجاه الميناء الرئيسي
سيفا ستوبل وهو يضم يعتبر ميناء رئيسي
للاسطول الذي يعتبر دره الاساطيل الروسيه
كما يكتب عنه في الصحافه بعد ذلك بدا
يشتمل على عمليات نوعيه هذه العمليات سواء
كانت بمهاجمه القواعد اللوجستيه او
بمهاجمه القواعد الجويه كقاعده شاكي او
بمهاجمه
بعض ناقلات النفط او بعض السفن سفن
الابرار تتالت العمليات السؤال لماذا
التركيز لماذا التركيز الاوكراني على شبه
جزيره القرم الاجابه من خلال متابعه تكمن
في عده نقاط اولا اوكرانيا لم تكف الحديث
عن عن شبه جزيره القرم وضروره عودتها
لانها تم السيطره عليها في عام 2014 وضمت
بناء على
الاجراءات القانونيه والدستوريه الروسيه
واجريت الانتخابات وحسم امرا واصبحت خارج
دائره النقاش يعني
تكمل فقط انوه بين هذه الصور الاوليه
تاتينا للهجوم على مقر هذا الاسطول في شبه
جزيره القرن تفضل
يا سيدي يعني دعني افصل ولو جزئيا ما بين
خصوصيه القرم وشرق اوكرانيا حتى بالنسبه
للجانب الروسي
يستطيع ان يحاجج بان القرم تاريخيا ارض
روسيا ثم تسليمها او الحاقه باوكرانيا في
عام 1953 زمن الرئيس خريشوف وبالتالي هذه
ارض هي تاريخيا ارض روسيا بينما الشرق
اوكرانيا هي ارض تدعي انها تقع ضمن روسيا
الجديده يوجد بها 60% من المواطنين ناطقين
باللغه الروسيه اذا هناك فرق في المقاربه
الروسيه هذه عرض بحكم التاريخ وهذه ارض
بحكم الديموغرافيه لهذا السبب الجانب
الاوكراني يتحدث باستمرار عن اعاده
السيطره واستعاده السيطره على شبه جزيره
القرم يضاف الى ذلك اهميه شبه جزيره القرم
في الواقع الحالي الميداني القتالي شبه
جزيره القرم وخلال من خلال جسر كيرش
وميناء
تعتبر القاعده اللوجستيه العملياتيه التي
تؤمن قدره الجيش الروسي على الاستمرار في
القتال وايصال المعدات سواء كانت بشريه او
معدات قتاليه او لوجستيه لهذا السبب من
وجهه نظر عسكريه لابد للجيش الاوكراني ان
يضع اولويات الاهداف التي تلقي بظلالها
على مجريات المعركه فسيجد بديهيا ان
الاولوي المطلقه هي شبه جزيره القرم
الاولويه الثانيه محاوله الوصول الى اطراف
والى منطقه الابراج في موسكو من اجل بعد
سياسي بينما في الجانب الاخر لا هي تبحث
عن هدف ذو قيمه استراتيجيه يقيم عسكريه
وذي قيمه
لهذا السبب تم التركيز بصوره كامله يضاف
الى ذلك عدم وجود قدره فعليه ميدانيه من
قبل القوات التقليديه ان تستطيع الوصول
الى الى شبه جزيره القرن الهجوم من شهر
حزيران الهجوم المضاد تعسر يحقق انجازات
بسيطه جدا بلغه الارقام سيطر على ما يعادل
200 كيلو متر على واجهه طول 1900 كيلو متر
بمعنى اخر مساحات محدوده اذا اخذنا هذا
كمقياس يعني ان امام اوكرانيا اشهر وربما
سنوات حتى تصل الى سواحل اوسوف او الى عمق
الزجاجه في شبه جزيره القرم اذا يجب البحث
عن البدائل ما هي البدائل عمليه المزاوجه
ما بين القدرات المتاحه متمثله بالطائرات
المسيره
متمثله بصواريخ ستور متمثله باستماره
البحريه والان ظهر الجديد رابع هذا العنصر
هو استخدام الضفادع البشريه يتم نقلهم الى
نقطه معينه يقوموا بالغوص تحت الماء يصل
الى اهداف محدده سواء لتثبيت صفائح
الكترونيه لارشاد القذائف او لعمليات
تدمير كما حدث في بعض الحالات اذا هذه
الرباعيه من الامكانيات المحدوده بدات
توظيفها بصوره جيده وبدات تعطي ثمرا اوليه
لا اقول انها ثمارا ناضجه بمعنى الكلمه
تلقي بظلالها عن مجريات المعركه لكنها
تبقي على شبه جزيره القرم داخل اطار
الصوره وتساعد على ادامه تقديم معلومه
وخطاب رسمي يومي من قبل الرئيس الى الشعب
الاوكراني
سواء كان في داخل البلد او بخارجها
ولتغطيه جزئيه على تعثر الهجوم المضاده
دكتور فايز ما علاقه هذا الحدث
بما طال الحديث عنه اقصد الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد
يا سيدي الان هناك تعثر شئنا يعني هذا
الواقع كان الحديث والتضارب الاقوال
وتباين الاقوال والتصريحات حتى بدات كانها
متناقضه ما بين فتره واخرى من قبل نفس
المسؤول في البدايه الهجوم التمهيدي ثم
الهجوم الرئيسي لم يبدا ثم نعم نقر بصعوبه
ثم نتحدث عن قدوم فصل الخريف وفصل الشتاء
ثم الحديث عن اشهر صعبه قادمه اذا هناك
رسائل متعدده جدا حتى لا اقول ترميك
المحلل انما تربك المشاهد على الاقل في ظل
في ظل تعثر الهجوم المضاد سواء كان الجانب
الاوكراني او حتى الجانب الروسي الجانب
الروسي كذلك في منطقه
هجومه متعسر اذا في حال تعثر القتال البري
ما هي واستمرار دائره الصراع ما هي
البدائل البدائل استخدام الوسائل المتاحه
الوسائل المتاحه الطائرات المسيره بصوره
عامه والصواريخ هنا يجب ان نتوقف لمن جميل
الكف من حيث لغه الاعداد ومن حيث القدرات
التقنيه تميل اصل كف لصالح الجانب الروسي
لديه مخزونات اكبر لديه قدرات صاروخيه
اكبر لديه امكانيه تاثير وفاعليه اكبر
لاحظ يكون عندك هجوم بثلاثه واربعين طائره
يتم الحديث عن اسقاط 36 لكن الحديث
المقابل عن ثلاثه اشارات في منطقه كورسك
وفي اطراف موسكو اذا هناك تباين بالقدرات
يلقي بظلاله لكن على الاقل تبقى
محاوله الوصول ولو بالطائره واحده الى هدف
لاهميه استراتيجيه يعادل ما يفوق قدره
وصول عشر طائرات الى اهداف تعبويه من خلال
متابعتك هل هل الحدث ما زال مستمرا الحديث
عن اخلاء الجسر مثلا هل هو في طور
الاستهداف
يا سيدي ما دام هناك مؤشرات ومعلومات
استخباريه ان هناك احتماليه الضربه من
وجهه نظر
لمراعاه السلامه يجب ان يتم ايقاف الحركه
سواء عبر جسر كيرش او عبر المطارات في
موسكو لاحظ عندما تقترب طائره مسيره
اوكرانيه من منطقه ابراج موسكو وهي على
بعد مئات الكيلومترات من المطارات الاربعه
المحيطه بمدينه موسكو يتم تعليق الحركه
لمده 60 دقيقه لمده 90 دقيقه حسب
خطوره المعلومه وامكانيتها احتماليه
النجاح فهذا اجراء احترازي وقائي لابد من
اتخاذه ولكنه اجراء يلقي بضلاله على البعد
المعنوي والنفسي وعلى البعد المادي من حيث
استخدام هذه المنشاه الاضافه التي
يشكلها الانزال تحدثت عن ضفادع بشريه
تحدثت عن محاوله للوصول الى سواحل القرم
ما الذي يضيفه هذا التكتيك الاوكراني في
شبه الجزيره
الان اذا تحدثنا دعنا نقول معركه البحر
بابعادها الجويه سواء صواريخ او طائرات
مسيره بابعادها البحريه كصواريخ قوارب
سريعه او ما يطلق عليها المفخخات البحريه
التي تسير موجهه تحت سطح الماء بمسافه
معقوله او باستخدام الضفائر البشريه لكل
نوع هدف ولكل نوع واجب محدد عندما نتحدث
شكرا جزيلا